welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode 6 the eye seriously
one of my favorite Star Wars anythings
and there's so many subtle details that
went into making it so great I'm gonna
break it all down for you the episode
opens with nimik pouring Cassie and some
calf Cassian is to hug his all Donnie
coat tight around him because as we see
later it doesn't really fit him properly
since he was a lead addition they had to
work with what they had nemec worries
that he couldn't sleep the night before
the mission because his Galaxy brain was
too preoccupied struggling to understand
why my faith doesn't calm me I believe
in something why am I so unsettled I
mean you have nothing
you sleep like a stone as a story of war
from the point of view of those on the
front lines this Echoes the quiet rest
period in Saving Private Ryan when the
soldiers discussed how to fall asleep
and now he doesn't
what's that falls asleep like that I
mean look at him the guys lights out the
middle of his head it's the back
clear conscience
yeah what's his name
God's on our side who the hell could be
on this
if God be for us who could be against us
that scene continues with the
heartbreaking monologue from the medic
Wade who says that his trick to falling
asleep was trying to stay awake like he
as a kid would do trying to wait for his
mother to come home Wayne and mimic are
parallel figures when you think about it
young morally pure Wade inscribing
carpazo's letter like how nimik
inscribes his Manifesto both these two
young guys becoming sort of Martyrs
nimik says he wrote about Cassie in the
night before the role of mercenaries in
the galactic struggle for freedom
my conclusion is simple
weapons are tools those that use them
are by extension functional assets we
must use to our best Advantage the
Empire has no moral boundaries why
should we not take hold of every chance
we can and if you think about it since
this would be nemic's final entry of his
Manifesto for Anyone who reads this text
in the future it will have a greater
significance as his closing statement
that is of course unless casting were to
continue to write in it like Frodo does
to finish Bilbo's story but I really
hope he does it but this Thomas Paine
Carl Marx's message inspired the
Rebellion unabridged really one could
imagine this Manifesto and lightning
Monmouth Senate mentee Leia Organa
inspiring her to one day accept the
self-interested Han Solo Cassian tells
nimik he'll sleep when it's done yes a
grim foreshadowing of how nimik will end
this episode finally able to rest Goran
supervisor Corporal j-hold bias
generalizes the danis to his guests the
Imperial engineer from Coruscant Colonel
pedagar he says that they've subjugated
these pilgrims by overwhelming them with
choices setting up Comfort units along
their pilgrimage with drinks to stray
them off their path and while that may
have worked for many of them the true
belief don't want his pelts they just go
along with this exchange to witness to
ivaldani from their sacred Temple this
whole idea of trading pelts definitely
mirrors the trade European colonizers
would make with American indigenous
tribes pelts for land but later we
learned that this tribe burns the pelts
not trusting them in the control room
the technician's screen shows the orbit
of the planet as it moved into the
crystalline belt that causes this shower
and it has the same design interface as
the screens in a new hope that shows the
death star's orbit into position now
thanks to Bessie for sponsoring this
video I'm obviously detail obsessed if
there's one thing driving me nuts about
Andor it's what's everyone wearing on
their feet if it were me if I were
trying to film mint a galactic Rebellion
against a well-armed foe I wouldn't want
to have to think about whether or not my
socks were wet Rebels don't have time to
dodge puddles so they probably wear
vessies that way they don't have to
think about it Bessie is here to keep
you looking good while keeping your feet
dry besties are the perfect everyday
shoe they are sustainably made knit
sneakers that are 100 waterproof they
are made with a dymatex material that's
super easy to clean with just a rinse of
water
oh no I spilled water all over my pizza
Wheaties but my Oinky oinkies are bone
dry like the Doom seeds
if the weather's wet or if it's muddy
vessies can help you besties are my
go-to shoes that are right by my door
check them out in the link below for a
pair of your own Vesti shoes as j-hold
and pedigars sipped their cap together
notice how j-hold's uniform looks like
it's been tailored compared to pedagars
and gorans it's got a wider black collar
and black extensions on the sleeves to
match with his black gloves like cereal
carton this guy is custom tailored his
suit but j-hold's case to take it out
some so that it will fit as his wife
roboda suggested perhaps you've expanded
Gorn tells j-hold I've brought in 30
centuries from Al Kenzie I'll have them
close at hand to supervise I've sent our
best men to The Primitives for insurance
yeah so Gordon sent away the sharpest
guards From the Vault to leave it more
vulnerable skein tells Cassian about
terman's past he was a stormtrooper
should have been doing since I found out
they slaughtered our whole family though
can we really trust Skeen especially
since theremin seemed less experienced
in Cassian when it came to which side to
march on last episode I'm just saying
his possible ski might have told Cassian
this to create some future division in
the ranks that he could exploit as
villain sent to uncover this aquatic
propeller the first Crystal shoots of
her head
yeah I love the sound design this
Crystal makes a kind of whale or a song
as it burns up in the sky setting us up
for thousands of these to join in a
course as they communicate with the rest
of the team they use the code names of
Valley one and Echo one Echo also being
the code name of the rebel base on Hoth
and Empire pedagogue fidgets with this
nerdy scope has it started
but the Donnies don't believe it ever
ends so yes sir it has definitely
started
porn is the guy who
fell eats every three years it's a
constant stream that's always part of
their lives which does align with Karl
Marx's dialectical materialism in which
social revolutions are not random
phenomena that come up every once in a
while they're really the cyclical result
of a constant undercurrent of material
oppression hey I'm not telling you how
to think I'm just saying for nothing
else read curl marks for a hot take on
history and technically the Donnies are
more accurate too because this isn't a
meteor shower of random space particles
crashing into the planet it's a destined
part of this planet's orbital path
through a crystalline belt that it hits
every three years their planet is always
on this orbit therefore the eye of all
Donny never ends and it never begins
Bell and since over here some guards
outside having locker room talk a good
look at her
patience was not the first thing that
came to mind yeah I think this might be
the first time human characters have
been depicted urinating
yeah I love the way this is worded it's
a greeting but it also carries a
backhanded subtext find some good within
you and I love how Gorn later uses this
as the translation of the chieftain's
threat to be us [ __ ]
foreign
says May the eye find the good in all of
us yeah j-hold ain't smart enough to see
the backhandedness of this Goran orders
the score
yeah skein totally bumps tarim in there
they're not the tightest operation but
also remember skein is looking for a
chance to bump them each off so the
squad makes their move they take the
family hostage there's a quick shot that
shows nimik shaking and pedagogue
notices this and pulls a blaster on him
pedagogue demands to release the boy but
in response scheme shoves the rifle
harder into that kid's head it's a
really quick shot and they only show it
for like half a second because yeah
that's a pretty insane thing to show but
the fact that it's included at all is
just another sign that skein is not the
nicest guy on This Crew tareman
backhands jailed well deserved after
j-hold's earlier threat to show his son
the back of his hand this whole mission
intercuts with the Donnies by their
bonfire and their musical chanting which
is their way of welcoming the celestial
event but it also has the effect of
raising the tension back in the base
with this natural ticking clock all the
music that Nicholas Patel could post for
this episode is just so intense I feel
like all this was his version of Hans
Zimmer's docking sequence music from
Interstellar so that by the end of it
you're just like yes let's go but the
Donny chant ends with them covering
their bonfire so they can better see the
sky the lights are being snuffed
paralleling the darkest minutes of the
mission inside and then minutes later
lights flood the sky in the shower to
represent the return of Hope back at the
Vault the guards are playing cards
saying words like hexba hexa hoxila the
hex prefix I assume connected the cards
means excited sabak uses six-sided cards
but those cards are longer this might be
a sebok variant Tara Mentos is being a
DLT 19 Blaster rifle fateful choice for
him because he later tells skein to
cover him with this and scheme does it
despite this rival actually allowing
more rapid fire skiing only fires one
shot to cover Terminator jayhold says
they won't be able to unlock the credits
inside the ball because it requires a
signal for Mount Kinsey but Gorn is
definitely able to blow the locks off
the stacks so this might have been
something the authorities from Al Kinsey
told j-hold to keep him and his men from
trying to steal the credits yet still
the blown locks do alert I'll can do
that wrongdoing as a foot it's kind of
like saying hey those security cameras
totally work and kind of like logically
programming your employees to ask for
permission not for forgiveness I love
how skein enters this Vault and you can
just see the greed pouring from his eyes
so when the elkinsi Call Comes in Santa
just shuts it up reminds me a lot of
Hans boring conversation anyway move and
A New Hope and then we cut to the akinsi
air base and I love this
yeah this might be my favorite shot of
the episode The Practical set the Tie
fighters hanging from above in a catwalk
that leads to each there's a Lambda
Class Shuttle parked in a hangar below
them and of course we hear the classic
Star Wars Claxton alarm siren blaring
and with that night sky lit up from
behind we see a pilot climbing down to
the cockpit and I think this is so great
because so many other Star Wars aerial
battles just showed Tie fighters
swarming in from out of nowhere like
locusts so instead here we start the
battle with each of these Imperial
Pilots individually climbing their
cockpits humanizing this enemy and they
do this in front of the same sky that
the rest of the characters are seeing
giving us a sense of their proximity and
raising our sense of dread and
throughout this sequence we continue to
intercut with these Thai Pilots
including them turning on their
targeting displays
yes this is the same sound effect use
invader's cockpit in the Trench Run
back in the vault a shootout ensues
kimsey shoots Gorn Cassian shoots kimzey
skein again intentionally fails to cover
terraman Cassian launches a trawler and
those heavy credits injure and paralyze
nimik and I don't think there's ever
been a better Marxist metaphor for the
crushing weight of capital from inside
the control room roboda and Leonard
watched the trawler jet off toward the
opening of the eye and indeed the sky
does look like an eye the streaming
crystals looking like the iris of it
this eye representing the Rebel's
ability to see the path forward but also
a terrifying eye of the Empire that is
now upon them but on a spiritual level
it does represent a giant Godly eye an
eye that judges all these characters
equally with nimik injured velas to hit
him with a men's Spike basically a shot
of adrenaline so that nimik can breed
off his old school star path unit that
again is made out of a 70s Polaroid
camera I love it this is the one that
nimix said could never be corrupted and
we hear more classic Trench Run sounds
from the Thai cockpit
but the sound it makes when it gets
locked on target gets stalled because
their sensors are glitching from the
celestial event nemic was right his
untethered Navigator saves them here and
notice how his Tech locks in
time
yes climb climb is the last word that
k2so will say to Cassian during the
Battle of scarif climb
climb mimics able to give them just the
right Vector so that they're able to
evade the shower the Crystal's cracking
the shielding on their trawler but
completely obliterating the three Tie
fighters
scream of one of those Thai Pilots Sinta
joins the pilgrims to watch the event
from the ground the Imperial guards
equally transfixed by the sky such a
beautiful moment that humbles and unites
them all in their common humanity and
giving all of us hope now this is not
the end for Sinta trailer footage showed
her back in that Valley on aldani
getting to a hidden Speeder Bike then
looking up to see a massive Star
Destroyer looming over the planet so
yeah the Empire will strike back skin
pushes to go to a doctor this kid is the
reason that we are here he is alive
sadly skein only wants him to go to the
doctor so that they'll have this road
stop where skin can try to sneak off
with the hall meet Dr quadpaw performed
by Aiden cook a puppeteer and past Star
Wars performer who played the mon
calamari katekin Lieutenant Admiral
radiss in Rogue one as well as benthic
and adrio two tubes who will return on
this series maybe as soon as next
episode now quad paw has four arms but I
guess Vel still has to hold the ID drip
bag it looks like those four arms were
done practically with a second actor
sharing the costume kind of like the
Helping Hands improv game his Planet by
the way looks so cool it's aggressive
dealed with a farm windmill in the orbit
of a massive gas giant but it looks like
oxygenated and hidden by a kind of
nebulous gas cloud the traitor skene
offers Cassian to split the 80 million
oh I'm a rebel it's just
me against everybody else skein even
denies having a brother with a pepper
Orchard he made all that up which also
means he concocted the story about his
brother drennon himself with stones in
his pockets this makes us reassess every
suspicious glance scheme Gabe Cassie
like when he first approached camp in
episode 4 ski must have been thinking
great someone else I gotta kill off or
bargain to split it with also skiing
going through his stuff scheme grabbing
the kyber Crystal from around his neck
and when Cassian admitted to them that
he was doing this repayment that must
have made skin the most uncomfortable
because he was still keeping a very
similar secret for himself skein says
there's a moon eight parsecs away but
Cassian shoots him dead
passing goes inside to see nemec did not
make it and quadbot races his inner set
of hands first followed by his second
set but Cassie is just taking the cut he
was promised leaving the rest and the
freighter devel and it's a token of
Goodwill he gives her Lutheran's kyber
Crystal to return to him Bell in
exchange gives Cassian nemix Manifesto
which nimik insisted Cassie and get so
nemec must have concluded that the only
way that his spark of hope would mean
anything would be if his message could
convert the most skeptical non-believer
and that right now is Cassian back on
Coruscant major particast tells the ISP
I want every Star sector and planetary
emergency retaliation plan in the
building ready for presentation by
midnight impressive how calm and
unrattled he seems like he definitely is
in crisis mode but it's also like he
expected such a possibility to happen
mon mothma speaks to the Imperial senate
about age of the Gormans that's the race
that she mentioned in episode 4 setting
up the Gorman Massacre that will lead
her to leave the Senate we see that in
Rebels notice how the Senate chamber is
largely empty most pods are vacant and
the occupied ones only have two seats
filled in from the senior senator in the
junior Center from that planet all the
seats behind those two are always empty
meaning the Empire has forbidden any
extra staff or guests to join them an
imperial Crest marks each pod and in the
central chair is seated one individual
seen only at a distance but they are a
pale figure with what looks like a bald
head I assume this is Sly more the
Environ age the emperor seen the
prequels who's actually mentioned is one
of the dinner guests back in episode 4.
the episode ends back in Lutheran's shop
it's a different blue there's an
inscription on that one
in the language no one remembers how sad
no it's liberating you decide what it
says
your own secret language deverin is a
jungle planet that appeared a few times
in Clone Wars of course Lutheran loves
this idea of a secret language as this
guy often uses these artifacts to speak
in his code these artifacts by the way I
had broken down plenty of other videos
from plokun's mask to the Starkiller
armor below of all tablets a gungan
shield some Jedi and Sith holocrons and
it's a random minion of Joe's Easter
eggs like the Sankara stones from Temple
of Doom and Indy's whip golden idol and
Boots Frozen and carbonate our final
shot shows Luton allowing himself
finally his first genuine smile on this
series it's definitely not the false one
that he puts on for show but just true
relief and joy for Stella Skarsgard
because the rebels just scored their
first major win something so big that
the ISB the Senate and the media cannot
ignore it you can follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at a bus follow
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye foreign
[Music]